"Damn. Stop it."
"I'm unbreakable. Unbreakable."
Patches: The Hyena. The spider. The Trustworthy. The Unbreakable.
The fact he makes it to the end of the world, never truly hollowing, is nothing short of incredible.
For we've come across countless undead who lost their humanity in pursuit of a purpose
yet long after they're gone, Patches remains.
Any undead who makes it to the end of the world is certainly worthy of a second glance.
For surely, Patches isn't as straightforward as he seems
though you'd be forgiven for thinking otherwise.
"There's a fine stash of treasure right down that hole..."
"I'll strip your corpse clean!"
"Wait now, you didn't actually fall down then; everybody makes mistakes."
"I'm not above it all, I swear. We're on the same side."
"I'm trusty Patches, the one and only!"
Patches is clearly in love with tricking everyone for profit
but for a man who allegedly reviles the greed of men
and claims to be devoid of all worldly wants
is the profit truly what drives him in this endless task?
I think his greed is a front
a facade designed to hide his true purpose
which is to punish the greed and the want of others.
"Every age it seems is tainted by the greed of men"
"Rubbish to one such as I, devoid of all worldly wants."
Time and time again we're lured by our greed
eventually finding a somewhat loyal friend in Patches after our punishment is delivered.
But across all these worlds there is one man that Patches truly befriends
and this friendship gives us a rare insight into what he values.
This friendship is with Greirat.
"Ah, I see you met Greirat. The slinking rodent."
"But he did me a good term back in Lothric Dungeon."
"Doubtless I should do something about that little debt."
"Well, maybe not."
"Well, I can hardly believe he's still standing." (laughs)
Greirat the thief once fancied himself a martyr for the poor
the Souls version of Robin Hood if you'd like.
It was his concern for others that led him to climb the great wall to Lothric
where he freed Patches from the Lothric dungeon
before being locked away in a cell of his own awaiting your rescue.
"I don't want to sit around and die a petty rat"
"and I consider myself your friend."
Indebted to you and with all those he loves dead
Greirat dedicates himself fully to your cause
even embarking upon suicidal thieving runs through the most dangerous territories.
It's these actions that lead Patches to his uncharacteristic concern.
"Hey, what happened to Greirat anyhow?"
"I haven't seen him at all lately."
"If you know where he's carried off to, be sure and tell me."
"Now I need to stock up, and if he's gone and croaked, he'll have left a gold mine"
(chuckles)
"What, gone all the way to Irithyll has he?"
"Huh, there can't be that much left of that frozen spool."
"The old rat, he's gone off the deep end this time."
He makes an effort to hide his affection for this man
though his actions betray that he cares.
For -dressed once again in the armor of the onion knight to hide his identity
it's Patches, not Siegward, that actually rescues Greirat in Irithyll.
"I might have died if it wasn't for that peculiar onion knight."
So of all the men to save, why Greirat?
Well Greirat is much like Patches you can see what they have in common.
They're both petty thieves, yet Greirat is one who acts without concern for himself.
He doesn't steal out of greed, so Patches respects him.
"Off to Lothric? The castle of no return?"
"That ol' thief's lost it if he thinks he has a chance in there."
"It's not like he's new to this game. What's got into him?"
Yet Patches also does outlive him.
The curse of life is the curse of want after all
and if we view greed as the reason that many hollow and die
then it makes sense that Patches is the one perfectly suited to resist the curse
by resisting want and greed entirely if he thrives upon punishing others for their greed.
So with no want and grounded by his desire to punish others for their want and to trick them and trap them
Patches makes it to the end of the world.
But slowly the world is ending
and soon there's no one left to lure into his traps.
There's no one else to trick with their own greed.
So it seems that Patches too, wavers in his duty
for here at world's end even he loses himself.
Which gives us a glimpse of the good heart that he used to have before the world made him what he was.
"I'm... a Hollow. Yes."
"I try to play it off, but I haven't a clue about my past."
"Who I was or what I lived for."
"Not even my own blessed name."
"You remember that treasure? Well"
"I fetched it for you. Here. Go ahead, it's yours."
"Maybe it'll help you with that solemn duty of yours."
"I'm off in search of the Purging Monument."
"Once I find it, everything will come back to me."
"Who I was; what I lived for."
"What my name was and what terrible grudges I held."
"I don't know."
"I just have this feeling that that's the kind of man I was."
The Purging Monument has the power to purge the undead curse
and restore one's humanity.
Ironically, only by displaying humanity can it be found.
"What did I come here in search of?"
"Damn. Stop it."
"I'm unbreakable. Unbreakable."
"Ah... Please."
"Someone tell me. Who am I?"
"Why am I here?"
With your help, Lapp can find the purging monument
and surely Lapp is to be trusted.
"Are you certain of that- no."
"Sorry I know you'd never lie to me."
"Thank you. Thank you kindly."
"I swear upon my birth name that I am your friend."
"No matter what might come out"
"no matter what I was, if you would do me the honor."
"Allow me to be a true friend. Always."
At first glance, what's to come simply seems like more of the same, from Lapp. From Patches.
"Finally you've come. Now I know exactly who I was."
"And for that, I've a little thanks to be giving."
"Go this way and peep past the broken staircase."
"Some awfully fine treasures, just sitting there all alone."
"It'll change your life."
The swift kick down a hole fills you with frustration
till you realize that he's actually kicked you where you want to go.
To the ledge that leads out of this graveyard.
A setback that allows you to move forward.
"Every age it seems is tainted by the greed of men."
"Rubbish to one such as I, devoid of all worldly wants."
(laughs)
"Hm.. I don't know. Maybe it's just the way we are."
"I'll stick you in my prayers."
"A fine dark soul to you."
For the first time, Patches helps you on your quest in a perfectly fitting way.
He sets you on the path to the church of Filianore
where he assists you one last time in your quest to weaken the lord's grip on the Ringed City.
He did always despise clerics, charlatans he calls them
and it's fitting beyond words that Patches would play a part in undoing the greatest lie of all.
Undoing the greed of the gods that's rooted in faith, in Filianore, and in fire.
Here, you both stand at the end of the world
undead, unbroken, yet we two could not be more different
Patches fought for no one but himself
for no cause other than to scoff at the greed of men.
But you, he's seen your kind time and time and time again, and he outlived you all.
Those who lost everything and grasped for the faintest glimmer of hope.
Kind-hearted fools doomed by the very light that guides them.
He's seen men throw away their lives for the truth, for to an undead life is meaningless
Patches probably figures, why seek the truth when greater men have tried and gone mad as a result?
Even with the truth in tow, there is no fate for us other than the loss of self.
Because even if you're selfless, you can't save everyone.
No... No matter how hard you tried, in the end you couldn't save a single soul
and the more you try to help, the more you fight against evil, the more you will lose.
Before you're doomed to lose those closest to you. Family, friends.
Some may even turn against you.
For even with your boundless compassion
no one can foretell the consequences of your good intentions.
All of this, it's just want and greed in some shape or another.
A desire to look back at something that made your life worthwhile.
Whether it's a thirst for knowledge.
A desperate faith.
Some petty revenge.
It's taken some crestfallen men eons to find something worth fighting for
and even then they're fated to lose it all.
For even the gods are in despair.
The lords shy from their duty
and the last fire is fading.
But something sets you two apart
and maybe the one thing that you both have in common
is that you never looked back?
Another thing I've never looked back from is switching from Skype to Discord
and you guys know that I've actually never done a sponsorship on this channel.
But this is the exception because I've never been approached by a company that I believed in until now.
Discord is free.
There's no ads
and it's your best option for chatting with your mates, creating your own server
and even for getting in touch with me because we now finally have our own public community server.
So click the link below and you can join us over where you can talk souls, lore and vidya
on a platform that's really just designed for us
and if you're a part of this server in a few weeks
then I want to do an event where I give you guys the chance to invade me in Dark Souls 3
and if you beat me, you get the chance to win some high-quality Dark Souls merch.
So stay tuned for that.
Thank you for watching this video as always, and I'll see you in the next one.